et vous venez d'où je viens d'Australie
team Shadok c'est que son calvaire est
sur le point de s'achever hirsute le
visage croisé l'homme de 51 ans était
porté disparu depuis deux mois il
dérivait en plein Pacifique avec à peine
de quoi survivre
ce n'est que du matériel de pêche et du
matériel de survie du matériel qui lui a
permis de se nourrir et de stocker de
l'eau depuis pour s'hydrater mais au
fait dans la région qu'est-ce qu'on boit
quand il fait chaud la bière est en la
boisson préférée de la région
on en boit quand même habituellement on
emploie une on envoie deux bah
maintenant on en boit trois on en voit
quatre quoi est-ce qu'il y a une heure
pour boire de la bière oh je pense pas
non non qui toi à 11h qu'il soit midi
qui soit 6h du moment qu'on a chaud on a
soif on boit de la bière team Shadok
devait rejoindre la Polynésie française
assimile kilomètres de là mais quelques
jours après son départ son catamaran est
frappé par la foudre et son système de
navigation détruit dès lors le marin
australien confirmé va dériver pendant
de longues semaines tout en adoptant les
bons réflexes la dernière chose qu'il
faut dans ce genre de situation c'est
avoir trop chaud car sinon transpire
mais il ne faut pas aussi avoir trop
froid car les frissons augmentent les
besoins en nourriture
le bleu tu veux une tasse de café ou
galerie
il faut partir à point le lièvre et la
tortue au fond le témoignage j'ai flatté
l'eau mais ce qui a aussi sauvé Tim
Shadok c'est la présence à bord de Bella
sa chienne avec qui la partager sa
nourriture et son eau un réconfort
permanent qui lui a permis de garder
espoir et aujourd'hui d'être en vie j'ai
traversé une épreuve très difficile en
mer j'ai juste besoin de repos et de
bonnes nourriture car ça fait longtemps
que je n'ai pas mangé je prends des
nouvelles de Marion toutes les semaines
elle va de mieux en mieux et on se
languit de l'avoir revenir ici sur le
plateau on lui trouvera une place quitte
à avoir 31 candidats à un moment je sais
pas comment gérer on sert à mais en tout
cas
mais non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
adopter le bon comportement voilà ce qui
est affiché sur les grilles entourants
ce chantier de la plage Jean Jaurès
dépend cartes nécessaires pour empêcher
des passants d'importuner les femmes
archéologues qui travaillent ici selon
la mairie de Saint-Denis victime de
harcèlement de rue sur leur lieu de
travail avec des propos à caractère
sexiste et sexuel leur rappelant comme
si c'était une réalité que c'était un
métier pour les hommes et qu'elle devait
rentrer à la maison
une voix grave j'avais besoin de la
grâce
je pense que vu qu'il y a des cons
partout
faudrait être plus faudrait que la
police soit là quoi vraiment tout ce
qu'on donne ses agissements on est tous
en débardeur parce qu'il fait chaud et
c'est une question de respect globale
genre c'est encore plus grave parce
qu'elles sont en train de travailler
mais je veux dire il y a aucune
circonstance ou c'est acceptable on est
en 2023 et les femmes et les hommes sont
pareils quoi
ça me rend triste parce que j'ai creusé
comme une dingue je suis complètement
dégoûté c'est une chanson qui est quelle
origine en quelle langue tu chantais
ukrainien
[Musique]
c'est quoi on va tous ta faut dire très
fort merci non mais vous avez besoin de
comprendre non mais ne faites pas non
mais faut pas non plus faire les
ignorants comme si un moment donné vous
étiez complètement hors sol c'est-à-dire
que on est dans les quartiers bien sûr
dans lesquels vous me vivez pas c'est un
peu le comprendre et que vous êtes dans
une carte là uniquement non mais vous ne
viviez pas pour beaucoup d'entre vous
donc vous n'y venez uniquement quand il
y a des sujets comme ça qui sont les
croustillants et la preuve et c'est
dommage et c'est dommage vous voyez
c'est c'est ce genre de réflexion
monsieur Bakayoko moi depuis le début je
vous donne la parole et je je j'espérais
avoir un échange plutôt serein et
respectueux pourquoi cette chanson
parce qu'elle me tient très à coeur et
que je comprends pas qu'on puisse se
battre encore en 2022 c'est c'est pour
ça que je la chante vous ne savez pas
d'où je viens vous ne savez pas où je
vis vous ne savez pas où il est six
personnes vivent d'où ils viennent
laissez-moi terminer s'il vous plaît
vous ne savez pas cela et pourtant vous
dites ah bah vous venez juste pour une
histoire qui fait le buzz même s'il faut
la c'est pas très honnête et c'est pas
très respectueux pas de panique tout
cela semble bien normal c'est le corps
qui réagit à la chaleur et qui active le
rythme cardiaque pour réguler sa
température constante autour de 37
degrés à Paris certains bistrot
facturent même les glaçons hashtag
canicule #hasleur c'est la faute de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon la canicule le
réchauffement climatique et la
facturation des glaçons c'est lui voilà
ce que tweet Ségolène Royal alors moi
quand je vois ça je me dis on va ouvrir
là dessus des glaçons qui sont
maintenant payants à Paris mais on est
chez les fous trop tard le piège s'est
refermé
les araignées n'ont plus qu'à récolter
le fruit de leurs efforts
sauf que alerte info publie bonsoir
Ségolène Royal pourriez-vous vérifier à
quoi vous réagissez avant de vous
engager à tweeter le compte que vous
citez
usure peut mon identité en plus de cela
l'information est fausse bonne soirée je
suis chayenne Miss Belgique 2022 on
m'appelle Miss Botox je comprends pas
pourquoi voilà ce que propose Mediapart
depuis la mort de Naël et les révoltes
qui ont suivi vous êtes témoin de propos
racistes et déplacés au travail votre
témoignage nous intéresse racontez-nous
si une collègue ou un collègue à
partager la cagnotte destinée aux
policiers qui a battu l'adolescent un
autre à qualifié au détour d'un café des
jeunes de quartiers populaires de
sauvage un chef à stigmatiser les
populations d'origine émigrée et une
fois la luciole prise dans leur filet
les chances de s'échapper sont infimes
son destin est scellé
[Musique]
mais phénomène étrange même morte la
victime continue de
[Musique]
brillerme de boîte aux lettres où ils
appellent régulièrement les gens à
dénoncer un tel et un tel et c'est comme
ça qu'il fabrique leurs papiers
d'ailleurs je vous invite à lire le
papier qui a suivi cet appel à la
délation qui est disponible sur le site
de Mediapart et qui est absolument
génial parce que en fait ils n'ont pris
que des témoignages à charge
soigneusement choisis parce que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont envoyé
d'ailleurs des témoignages sur le
racisme anti-blanc et qui ont écrit avec
Mediapart pour faire valoir bien sûr
vous ne trouverez rien sur le racisme
anti-blanc dans cet article
avec ce que je gagne je peux aider ma
mère
les Mayas n'ont pas disparu leur force
et leur sagesse sont ancrées dans leur
descendants
ce ne doit avoir honte de son travail
car celui qui travaille sera récompensé